um before you go obviously you want to
get into the movie [ __ ] what is what are
your favorite give me your top three
movies all time top three movies yes
The Godfather series okay we'll combine
them all
um
you ever seen due date yeah I've seen
due date yeah with uh Robert Downey Jr
and Zach Galifianakis yeah
Indecent Proposal okay now that's a very
diverse three yeah I had to give you all
three I couldn't just do all straight
gangster movies nah I love it all
straight funny movies yeah did a love
story yeah gangster [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] there it is and it's probably
the top of those categories too I
disagree wholeheartedly about due date
it was okay dude they was funny bro it
was funny but it wasn't like funny that
[ __ ] was hilarious it was funny he drunk
his father's ashes right no it was funny
yeah and when he was realized he told me
because he drunk ass he drunk some more
eggs so stop I don't know if I don't
know if I'd even put it in my top 30
funny movies
funny I need your top five funny movies
Friday
old school
it was old school with Will Ferrell okay
no I'm gonna throw another Will Ferrell
movie in there
Step Brothers Step Brothers okay
super bad
super bad The Big Lebowski the poster
that's my favorite movie ever it's
technically accommodates behind you
that's my favorite movie of all time
that's funny it is my favorite movie
ever it's funny though yeah it's funny
it's funny as [ __ ] yeah it's the whole
movie starts with these so there's two
people named Jeffrey Lebowski who live
in LA one of them is a millionaire one
of them is like a [ __ ] loner who's
broke as [ __ ] living off unemployment
and this the millionaire owes somebody
like a hundred thousand dollars so the
goons knocked down the cheap dude's door
beat the [ __ ] out of them piss on his
rug
not realizing they got the wrong Jeffrey
Lebowski until it's too late they
already pissed on his Rook so the poor
Jeffrey Lebowski really loved his rug
because it tied the room together
so he takes the rug he rolls it up and
he finds the rich Jeffrey Lebowski it's
this old white guy he brings the Piston
rug to his house
gets a meeting with him and says hey I'd
like you to cover the cost of my rug
because they were looking for you not me
man and I love my rug
and that's it and then it just it's wild
from there it goes into like some wild
[ __ ] it's crazy it's such a wild movie
we're kind of I find that movie yet
Netflix Amazon Prime I don't know if
it's on Netflix but it might be on um
Amazon yeah I mean I own like seven
versions of it so I just give you one I
got it on Blu-ray I got it on [ __ ]
special edition Blu-ray I got it I'm
[ __ ] I bought it online
really good to me it's it's my favorite
movie of all time okay gotcha yeah and
then I gotta give you one more comedy uh
let's do uh
[ __ ] comedy
I would say yeah I already said Friday
uh
how high was great how high was like
nostalgic for me but I honestly think
like uh
hangover was up there man because
hangovers oh [ __ ] yeah hangover was
funny the first one yeah the next two or
whatever but the first one was pretty
wild you think about bad boys three
it was all right Bad Boys 2 was my
favorite yeah that was three was a
little kind of a letdown we waited all
this [ __ ] time just for the movie to
be in
did you like it I think I think they did
great on the graphics I mean yeah but
[ __ ] the graphics I wanted to laugh Bad
Boys 2 is the best one though Bad Boys
you're the best one for sure where the
little dude knocks on the door trying to
take his daughter on a date and they
[ __ ] break that [ __ ] is Iconic yeah
that's classic for sure and he's wearing
the Tim Hardaway Heat jersey the whole
[ __ ] movie that [ __ ] just back to my
childhood man yeah